[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis
weltreise gibt es kein video aus meiner
küche heute bin ich on tour und zwar
erwartet mich meine freundin lisa die
lisa d ist schwanger und bekommt
demnächst öbb und ich werde heute ihren
babybauch formalen also vor langer
langer zeit vor etwa zweieinhalb jahren
ungefähr hat elisa nämlich meinen bauch
gemahnt das seht ihr in diesem video da
können da gerne noch mal reinschauen
heute bin ich dran und die liest denkt
dass wir heute nur die begegnung machen
aber wir werden heute noch eine baby
party machen das heißt wir werden sie
später überraschend das weiß sie aber
noch nicht und deswegen geht es jetzt
einfach noch zu bieten
ich fühle mich ziemlich nicht hört mal
im laden
halo hat ihr motiv ausgesucht den
elefanten ich lieb' elefanten dass mein
name jetzt gleich 38
ich habe so was mitgebracht
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich den kleinen baby dom wo
einfach mit einem kajalstift
aufgezeichnet und das macht man am
besten immer im stehen den tipp habe ich
von der lisa denn der mann sitzt dann
wird der bauch so ein bisserl
zusammengedrückt und dann ist eben das
motiv nicht mehr so wie im stehen und
wir machen ja später die fotos auch im
stehen von daher passt es jetzt so ganz
gut und jetzt mache ich noch ein paar
feinheiten und dann kann es schon als
ausnahmen geben
zum ausmalen verwende ich ganz normale
haase und nehmen dann hauptsächlich
geschminkt haben
wird in süßen dumbo nehme ich jetzt ein
hellblau und den hellgrauen möchte
fragen das sind blau entstehen und die
licht- und schatteneffekte die mache ich
dann mit etwas schwarz und weiß und dann
müsst euch einfach im klaren sein dass
von einer seite das licht kommt das
heißt bei mir scheint das licht auf dem
buchrücken und deswegen nicht die linke
seite ein bisschen heller und die rechte
seite ein bisschen schattiger
[Musik]
für den innenteil der ohren nämlich sein
helles rosa und mich ein bisschen geld
rein und auch ein bisschen weiß und
malta mit dem bus dieser orden aus
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt alles grund hier mit den
schmink farben und jetzt nämlich einfach
einen eyeliner und kann damit noch die
einzelheiten machen jetzt im moment
erkenne noch nie so viel aber im prinzip
ische verständigt werden
und dann kommt auch noch ein bisschen
schöner pass produkt die mama das gerne
[Musik]
mit dem schwammkopf ich jetzt hier noch
im hintergrund ein bisschen und da kann
man einfach richtig schön die übergänge
machen und ich glaube wir sind dann auch
demnächst fertig
[Musik]
kommt zum schluss natürlich noch ein
bisschen
[Musik]
also lisa wie ich wir haben jetzt noch
ein paar tipps für euch weil es ja auch
mal der babybauch vermahlung machen
wollt also tipp 0 1 das motiv malt man
immer im stehen
denn im sitzen zusätzlich muss ja dann
drückt das immer so ein bisschen
zusammen
tipp 2 nimmt ein großes motiv also bei
uns jetzt dumbo und schönes rundes motiv
vor allem auch was eben gut auf dem
bauch draufpasst tipp3 einmal am besten
vorzeichnen auf papier wenn man jetzt so
viel man also wenn es direkt auf den
bauch gemacht aber normalerweise übt man
auf dem papier
was ich electric guitar grip da muss auf
jeden fall sein und schöne warme farben
sind ja und natürlich welche farben
verwendet man also immer hautfarben
schminkt farben nehmen weil das eben
auch nicht auf der haut und das denn
jetzt wasserlösliche farben also die
sind jetzt auch schon trocken und dann
schmiert das auch nicht und im prinzip
kannst du sitzt auch bis morgen drauf
lassen wenn sie möchte bis zur geburt
sei bislang aber das waren sie unsere
tipps jetzt immer fertig sondern jetzt
werden gleich die fotos gemacht und
dafür brauchen wir noch ein paar
blümchen und eine schöne location wo ich
gerne die fotos
[Musik]
es gibt ganz tolle effekte richtig schön
da haben wir uns eine schöne gegend und
ein paar schöne bilder geschossen und
ich glaube aber was schön ist dabei gar
für dich ja ebenfalls ist im prinzip
jetzt unser tag noch nicht vorbei aber
für euch das video vorbei und im
anschluss steht ihr einfach noch ein
paar schöne fotos und ich hoffe euch hat
das video spaß gemacht vielleicht
probiert er es selber mal aus falls er
aus der umgebung seit können da unser
besuchen
diese angebote nicht soll auch ein paar
bevor ich hab keine zeit du musst die
machen hat spaß gemacht oder zufrieden
der kleine dumbo alle gespannt auf das
kleine baby leyen
der kommt ja bald also viel spaß euch
noch einen schönen tag und morgen gibt
es ein richtig cooles video also
fußballs
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu deiner babyparty
[Gelächter]
nur zum essen kommen
[Musik]
überreicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]